hello my name is jeff del merico i'm a
research scientist
at the mixed reality and ai lab in
zurich switzerland
uh part of microsoft mixed reality and
on behalf
of my colleague helen olenikova i'd like
to welcome you to
our webinar entitled mixed reality and
robotics
unlocking more intuitive human machine
collaboration
but before we get started i'd like to
introduce some of the the concepts and
terminology that
we'll refer to during this presentation
so first we should define what is mixed
reality
so mixed reality exists on a spectrum
between the digital and physical worlds
uh
virtual reality on one end is a fully
artificial environment
where you're immersed in purely virtual
content
augmented reality visualizes virtual
objects overlaid on the real world
and gives the user an opportunity
to see the real world enhanced with this
digital
world mixed reality sits in the middle
and offers the opportunity for an
immersive
experience where the user can both
visualize
and interact with the digital world
through
a mixed reality device
and so this takes the form of
currently many different types of
handheld mobile devices such as
ar capable phones and tablets
and also vr headsets and mixed reality
devices like the microsoft hololens
and so these all we consider
having some capabilities that fall into
mixed reality devices
we're also interested in talking about
robots and these also take many forms
from industrial robots that perform
manufacturing to logistic robots and
move things around in a warehouse
to uh ground-based and also aerial
inspection
uh robots and uh service robots and so
on
so these uh take a really wide variety
of forms where today going to be talking
mostly about interacting
with mobile ground robots but many of
the principles that we talk about here
are applicable to a broad class
of robot devices and
we want to bring these mobile
these these robots and mixed reality
devices together
in a our vision of the
workplace of the future in which humans
and robots
can work together and collaborate in an
intuitive way
with one another allowing human
capabilities and robot capabilities to
complement one another
and one of the key um
one of the key functions here is that
the humans
and the and the robots need to share an
understanding of the space that they
occupy
and operate in and so that's one of the
major
themes of of today's webinar is
co-localization
the other one is interaction and so this
is
a quick video showing one
type of interaction that we want to
enable with mixed reality
which is gesture control so
the first half of this webinar will
focus on human robot interaction
and and then i'll turn it over to my
colleague helen for
the other half on co-localization
so the current popular
interaction paradigm for controlling
robots typically involves
sitting behind a normal desktop computer
or laptop
using a keyboard and mouse the
operator and the robot aren't
necessarily sharing the same space
and any spatial information that the
user wants to communicate to the robot
or the robot needs to communicate to the
user has to be translated
from from the robot's frame of reference
to the users one of the other things
that is
challenging in this paradigm is that the
user can't easily see the robot's
intentions
so one of our or some of our goals for
mixed reality based
human robot interaction is to enable
this natural mode of interaction and
cooperation and because
we can use mixed reality to visualize
things from the robot's reference frame
we're able to demonstrate uh you know
to to show the robot's intentions and
improve safety and transparency for
uh what the robot is doing and we also
want to be able to enable
new applications and uh and research
avenues
uh that that come out of this these
different ways of working with robots
and so in this talk we'll talk a little
bit about the current technology that
exists
and some of the tools for developing in
this space
as well as spatial data representations
in mixed reality and also based on the
capabilities
of your mixed reality device different
modes of of interaction
in mixed reality
so to start when we talk about mixed
reality devices
as i said the um
devices exist on sort of a continuum and
this uh these devices interact with
two different degrees the physical world
and the digital world
and so when we think about augmented
reality we have
some of the ar capable mobile devices
that use android or ios and their ar
libraries
to generate and visualize ar content
sort of at the other fully digital end
of the spectrum
we have some virtual reality devices
that that allow you to have an immersive
vr experience and there are also quite a
few
uh mixed reality headsets now that uh
including microsoft hololens one and two
that
sit kind of in the middle and allow you
to interact both with physical and
digital objects
simultaneously we want robots to sit
here in the middle as well because they
exist obviously in the physical world
but
they generate and interact with
digital data so whether it's their
sensors or
maps that they have of the space that
they're operating in
they naturally
interact with the the digital world as
well and so
uh we see robots as just another class
of mixed reality device
and i'll talk about sort of the
two most relevant uh classes of
of uh mixed reality devices uh at least
with respect to
uh to what we offer from microsoft so
augmented reality on mobile devices
you can see digital content as an
overlay on the real world
and to some degree interact with it
through the
multi-touch interface on the mobile
device so in this case
you can see uh a little gif from
the uh from the um
minecraft earth game where where you can
have a
an augmented reality game board in your
space
and and overlaid on on your real world
um there's um
you know a lot of a lot of ar content
and apps that that leverage ar core and
ar kit
and also research in this direction
using
augmented reality robots for
co-localization
but often this gets done with uh with
fiducial markers
which is something helen will talk about
more later
the other key e-class of devices
is is immersive is mixed reality
headsets like hololens 2.
and this new device
relatively new now offers the ability
to not only visualize
mixed reality holograms but also
interact with them
using kind of fully articulated hand
tracking
and eye tracking which i'll talk a
little bit more about later
these different ways that the device is
able to sense
the users um
uh the user's means of interacting with
the digital content we can leverage
these same things
to interact with robots and so really
the
hololens is a kind of a
moving sensor platform so you have a
number of different sensors on board
packed into a very small form factor you
have four
head tracking cameras that track how the
device moves
through the environment you also have a
depth camera
that has two different modes one
short throw helps for tracking your
hands the long throw mode
helps to map the environment and you
also have
some small ir cameras that track
the eyes as well as microphone away
array and another
rgb camera so there are a lot of sensors
on board all of these sensor streams
are potentially useful
in interacting with robots but what's
interesting is that many of the same
operations that the hololens is doing as
far as
tracking how it moves and understanding
its environment are exactly the same
problems that a robot needs to solve in
order to understand
its environment and operate there
so to give a sense of what hololens 2
does
with these sensors the head tracking
cameras
track a bunch of features in the
environment
and perform highly accurate visual
inertial odometry
along with the imu and this algorithm is
highly optimized for power
so over long trajectories can can track
how
you're moving your head
and simultaneously you have the depth
camera sensing the environment
alternating between the short throw and
long throw modes
in order to both track the user's hands
and
and map the environment and so all of
this depth data
gets fused into a
spatial mesh of the environment and
this allows the hololens to
to project holograms in the right place
so that they're not
say behind a wall and also be able to
understand
some semantic aspects of the environment
such as which parts of the mesh are
walls and what is floor what are other
surfaces that you could put holograms on
and so with all of these different
processes running simultaneously
the hololens is able to build up a very
rich
spatial representation of the
environment which is
uh very useful for visualizing digital
content for the user
but it also allows the hololens to have
an a rich understanding of the
environment
that it can share with with other agents
such as robots
and among the ways that the hololens
can can
allow the user to interact with digital
content
is with with this fully articulated hand
tracking in which
the user is able to really just reach
out and touch
holographic holographic content
and manipulate it which makes for really
intuitive
interaction with these digital objects
and we can leverage that also
in interacting with with robots
and the way this looks is it's like this
um
and so the you really do get
tracking data for all of the all of the
parts of the hand
and it's it's really
quite robust
and and what's interesting
is that this was actually trained purely
on synthetic data
and um and
and is able to really adapt well to a
wide variety of
uh of users and and background
environments
finally the eye tracking capabilities
allow you to use your gaze
to to direct
either to control the control
holograms and uh and also obviously
we uh we are interested in trying to
leverage
this mode of interaction for uh for
robots as well
so vr headsets on the other hand um
really only allow an occluded view of
uh the environment you can only
visualize digital reality
there is one exception to this which is
called path through plus
from uh for some oculus headsets which
allow you to
uh they use they re-project the images
that the uh
that the cameras on the device that help
to
track how it moves they reproject those
uh to the displays on the inside of the
device so you can kind of see
through to the outside um albeit with a
limited field of view
um but uh but that's one exception uh
i don't know of any work in in that area
for
um for doing kind of mr control of
uh of robots but uh that's maybe a
possibility
and there's also some functionality for
vr headsets to do
hand tracking rather than using
controllers which are pretty typical
and there's a few other sort of um
a few other types of of ways that we can
mix
the the real world and the digital world
so
one of them is the mixed reality capture
there's a studio
uh that's part of microsoft that allows
you to do
like high resolution volumetric capture
with a lot of a lot of cameras that
allow you to basically generate
really uh nice looking holographic
content from
real world um uh from
from uh real people or or objects
and uh and then you can uh visualize
these
through an mr device as a hologram
uh another uh sort of uh
another way of visualizing uh real world
and
digital data together is uh is with
uh what's called oculus mixed reality
capture that allows you to
visualize yourself into the the game
content
as far as i know neither of these have
been explored for interaction with
robots but
as you can see with all the different
types of devices and different ways
of of blending the real world
and the digital world there are a lot of
opportunities still
to explore for leveraging
the physical and digital worlds for uh
for robotic use cases
so now that we've talked about devices
we can discuss a little bit about
how about the development
ecosystem for um for
building applications that leverage
mixed reality
for uh for robots so
the biggest thing is communication so uh
being able to
communicate between devices is uh is
typically
a challenge and uh and this is a
challenge
whether you have mixed reality devices
at all even just between robots
um it's also you know one of the the
most central
um aspects of a of a robot system
especially a distributed one across many
different
robot devices is how are you going to
send data back and forth
on mobile devices
you have the option to use a package
called ross sharp
with a rosbridge that facilitates
communication there's a few other
options for android and ios
ross here stands for robot operating
system which is not an operating system
but a communications
framework that is popular in both the
research and commercial domains
for mobile robots
and and the raw sharp package
enables this to work with c-sharp
projects and uh
luckily that also works for hololens and
uwp
applications um there are a few other
options also for hololens
but because both of these
[Music]
use cases are supported by rosh sharp
and rasbridge this seems to be
for now the best way forward
for communicating between your
mixed reality device and your robot
there's a number of development
platforms that enable
the user to create 3d content
and build spatial applications that can
then
um that can then interface with
uh with a robotic agent um unity
and unreal are both um game engines that
have found a lot of use
in more general 3d computing
and there's also
the open xr standard which is
is looking to sort of
make a make
mixed reality content available to a
wider variety of devices
through standardization there's also
the web xr which is a javascript library
that allows you to
have have 3d content on the web
and sort of building on
the sort of the basic development
platforms
you have a few options for um
for uh getting components into your
mixed reality applications that allow
you to easily build
interaction uh and interfaces for
user experiences so one of them is ptc
euphoria which is
um which is a a framework
mostly targeted targeted at enterprise
applications
for building ar and mr applications
across different different platforms
there's also microsoft's mixed reality
toolkit
which is available for both unity and
unreal engine
that if you look in the bottom left here
it gives you a bunch of different
a bunch of different components for
for adapting to your application that
allow you to interact
in different ways whether it's through
through hand manipulation or eye gaze or
different ways that you can you can
easily interact
these pre-built holograms will allow you
to uh to
easily get the user's input for the user
experience
this is also compatible with with ross
the robot operating system which makes
it
a compelling tool for
for integrating into a robotics project
in this space and finally there's a
project called arviz
which adapts the arviz visualization
utility from roth
for mixed reality devices
so what kind of data is is useful
for to visualize as i mentioned before
robots
typically have a bunch of sensors on
them and
while it's possible to visualize all of
this data
you see from a few of these examples
that if you
if you look at if you try to visualize a
mesh or
the robot's raw sensor data you might
end up including half of your
field of view with uh with opaque
holograms and so
that's something at least to consider in
building a user experience in
mr that deals with with robot data is
what kind of data is is
provides the most information to the
user and also doesn't
uh interfere with their ability to view
the
the real world that they might also be
trying to interact with so
good ideas for this include paths or
frustration of the camera what it's
looking at
the current robot state or
reference frames for for the
robot's map origin or
or its goal location
and another thing to consider when
working with spatial data
is uh that you're typically going to be
dealing with many different reference
frames so
in order to share spatial information
between
mixed reality devices and robots you'll
first need to co-localize
your your two devices that'll be the
focus of the second half of this
presentation
um but you'll also have to deal with
handedness of your coordinate system
so for example unity is left-handed uh
ross and others use right-handed
coordinates
you also need to deal with different
orientation conventions so hololens
uses y up while ross uses z up
and so on these are all small details
but important to keep in mind
there are many different ways to
represent spatial information
and to make this easier on yourself if
you are using ross
it's a good idea to leverage tf
the package for handling transforms
which will do this for you
most of this and there's also some
functionality built into
raw sharp to handle the conversions
between
left-handed and right-handed for between
unity
and roth so a lot of this can be taken
care of with careful use
of the existing tools
so different modes of interaction
um if you're working in the in the
physical reality
your uh possible ways of interacting
with robots
typically with joysticks um or
controllers as you can see on the left
uh and also kind of traditional keyboard
and mouse
where you interfa interface with the
robot using
some visualization program
augmented reality it ends up looking
like this where you can
use buttons or click on
parts of the of the screen to indicate
position and space if your augmented
reality device
is localized to the same space as your
robot then you can
visualize uh spatial data from the robot
overlaid on your view of the real world
through the
ar device which you can see here the
position of the robot
says blue sphere path is these red dots
goal is this white and green marker
and in mixed reality you have some more
options
for actually interacting with
uh with the digital content instead of
through screen
in ar you can actually use your head
pose
your eye gaze you can
touch or move holograms
and you can also point to distant ones
with your hands and so
this offers kind of a more rich
palette of uh of modes of interaction
for um for communicating
with robots
finally uh in virtual reality
you have also head pose but typically
your way of interacting with any of the
digital content is
with with controllers which do have some
advantages for
for manipulation because you can
much you know somewhat easier interact
with with distant
with distant digital content and you
have a bunch of
buttons for other functionality so there
are some advantages to using controllers
rather than your hands
but it's maybe a little bit less natural
so some final considerations when you're
developing a mixed reality application
for working with robots
your basic system architecture might
just be
your mixed reality device communicating
with
your robot but you might also
because of limited computational power
on your hololens and your robot
you might have some things running on
your um
on a base station or um
or laptop computer nearby that's on the
same network
um you might even if you're working with
a complex application
you might be using some cloud services
that need to interface with all of these
devices so your communication might
become somewhat challenging over time
as your the complexity of your
application grows
so this is something else to consider in
designing
your uh your system and whether you want
to
depend on communication
uh with like cons a persistent link to
the internet
or uh or not in uh in the capabilities
you can provide
so to briefly summarize this first half
of
the webinar about interaction
the goal that uh that we see for
interaction
is is to enable human robot teamwork
and there are currently
many devices available that enable
some capabilities in this direction
across the mixed reality spectrum
and these different types of devices
based you know depending on their
capabilities offer
different modes of interaction and
visualization of
robot data and
all of this really depends on
being able to have a shared spatial
understanding of
of the world between the mixed reality
device
and the robot and that is the topic of
the second half of this of this webinar
so now i'm going to hand it over
to my colleague helen who will take
take over for the second half
thanks for the introduction jeff i'm
helen olenikova a senior scientist at
the mixed reality and ai lab in zurich
same
as jeff and i'll be talking about how to
co-localize robots and mixed reality
devices
there's a few different types of
co-localization that we need to talk
about
the first type is when a person knows
where the robot is relative to them
so the relative localization between the
device and robot is known
uh so for example the person can see the
robot state and intentions they can see
any
path that's been planned and the second
type is where the robot knows where a
person is so this can be used for
for example um avoiding the human
in robot path planning and can lead to a
much more natural interaction experience
as in the come here demo
and finally the the most rich of the
types of colonization is when the robot
and the person are both localized in the
same global coordinate system and they
can share information that they both
have about
the space so we'll discuss a couple of
different
methods of co-localization so the first
and possibly most commonly used is
marker-based so this includes a
wide variety of ar markers such as april
tag aruco
ar toolkit view mark and so on and so
forth similar to the ones you see on the
right here
then there's also vision based
approaches so
these basically use visual information
so
image features and so on in the
environment to
provide localization information so this
includes azure spatial anchors which
we'll discuss in some detail
google cloud anchors apple location
anchors and so on
and quite a lot of different methods in
research
and finally we'll briefly talk about
common maps so this is
using different localization schemes or
different sensors between the two
devices to
find a common coordinate system by
localizing
themselves in a common map
so first we'll discuss a little bit
about marker-based co-localization
how it works advantages and
disadvantages
so how do localization markers work so
here you see a picture of
a a group of robots each with markers
mounted on them so basically the
algorithms work by detecting this quite
distinctive black and white pattern in a
camera image
and what's really powerful about the
markers is you can actually
differentiate different marker id so
each of these robots
has a different marker id which is shown
in a different pattern
and this means that by just looking at
this image you're able to get
all of the poses of all of the robots
relative to the camera frame so that's
that's quite powerful and there's a
couple of different ways to use them so
um one way is to have all of the devices
use their onboard cameras so here we
have a hololens 2 a mobile phone and a
robot
all of the devices use their cameras to
find where the
marker is mounted statically in a scene
and then from that information uh by
using the the shared coordinate system
they're able to localize themselves with
respect to the marker and by sharing the
data where
all three of them are relative to the
marker they can localize
each other another potential system
is similar to what we saw in the
previous photo with the multiple robots
is to actually have the tag on the
object you want localized relative
to yourself so here the hololens and the
phone are both detecting
a marker that's actually mounted on the
robot and by calibrating the marker
pose uh to the robot's uh
you know baselink frame or some static
part of the robot
then you're able to get a full
transformation between the cameras of
the sensors and the robot
keep in mind this gets a little bit more
complicated if the robot is moving
and with latency and network delay so
you'll have to
this method is a little bit more
complicated in that regard
so uh what are the pros and cons so
again markers are super commonly used
for a wide variety of
ar and mr applications so they're they
give you very precise positioning so on
average and this depends on a huge
variety of factors including
camera resolution the quality of the
calibration
how well the marker is printed how far
away you see it from
what angle you see it from and so on but
in under good conditions you can get sub
centimeter and sub
uh degree accuracy under such conditions
it's fairly fast so if you decimate the
image down and so on
kind of an average performance is about
22 milliseconds per image on a
slow-ish computer so it's fast enough to
run on mobile devices
and onboard robots so again quite quite
good there it's cheap and easy
widely supported many varieties you can
you can pick you know
any flavor of air tag and get kind of
similar performance
um the the big downside is you need to
actually do something to your
environment or to the robot to be able
to use this so you can't just show up in
a new space where you haven't done
anything with a new robot and and be
able to use it you need to
go around taping tags you have to make
sure no one
takes them off at night or you know
moves them
or on the robot again you have to make
sure that the tag is
rigid with respect to the robot
and uh so basically all the agents you
want to interact have to be looking
at the same tag or series of tags and
then you can do quite complex multi-tag
setups where you
basically create a sparse graph of tag
locations relative to one another but
this again
this gets quite complex if one of the
tags moves
what does this mean for the map if you
observe five tags and one of them is out
of place what does this mean for your
map and so on and so forth so this this
quickly grows in complexity for the
problem
but for for quite simple scenarios this
is often a great solution and
really fast and easy to implement
and of course the accuracy is a
viewpoint dependent so if you're
you know seeing a tag on a really weird
uh
thin angle you're going to have much
worse accuracy than if you're looking at
it head-on
so a little bit of detail about how one
of the
ar tags works just so you get a sense
for for the general algorithms and
pipelines that it takes to do this
so here we'll use the example of april
tag two which is a paper by john wang
and edwin olsen
please check out their paper for more
technical details and
many more cool figures so here we see
the original image which is taken with a
normal color camera this could be from a
phone from a robot
whatever then the next step is to do
edge detection so here you can see the
edges in black and white
this is just done by adaptive
thresholding on the edges
then all of the edges are clustered into
connected components so basically all of
the edge groups that are touching each
other are separated
and then in these clustered components
they detect quads so rectangles
uh squares and other quadrilaterals so
these are kind of the the candidates for
for the outer sheep
and then after the
correct size markers are found then they
kind of
extract the the the contents of the
quads they unwarp it and then from that
they're able to get
the actual ids of the tags which are
what's overlaid here
so again fairly simple system but you
can run this quite quickly
you can do gpu acceleration on this and
so on so
it's quite flexible and fairly robust in
the presence
of for instance camera distortion and
other effects
so how does this work in practice so
here we see a video from robotis
on how they're using um ar tags to
actually dock their robot
so uh this is kind of a mock-up of how
they would do
wireless charging for docking so the
robot is able to
just kind of spin around in the space
and then very accurately
uh come home by just using a camera in
its relative position to this tag
so again if you imagine you had a
wireless charger here you have a
complete wireless charging solution
of course you know i you can also use
this
uh directly with augmented reality here
it's actually a qr code
and they're on um here they're rendering
on top of the qr code a robot arm which
you can control from unity this is done
with uh
euphoria um and so you can see when the
person actually picks up the cure
code it's very because it's so fast to
detect these types of markers
the robot moves live and you're you know
you're able to
very easily interact with with these
markers and manipulate them
and this is again not work from us this
is work for the bernou university of
technology
uh so next up we'll talk about an
alternative if you can't instrument in
the
the environment or for some reason you
don't want to
or you know you want to use the the
information about the environment for
other applications and that's
vision-based co-localization
uh so there's uh kind of a standard
pipeline that's very
frequently used in computer vision and
robotics so here we we take
um some work from bernard zeissel
and his work with mark polo face on
using photographs to build and augment
3d models so again
not our figures so the first step is
to basically extract features
from an image by kind of finding
corners and kind of distinctive
locations in the image
and getting their description and then
assuming you already
have built a 3d model you can add a new
query image
in there you can extract local features
there as well
then to compare to the 3d model you have
of the space you can do
2d to 3d correspondences through
descriptor matching so
this means kind of taking the local
patch around the image features
and then comparing it to local patches
around
image features in the pre-built map
then from these course from having
enough of these correspondences you can
create
you can basically figure out what the
sixth degree of freedom poses
and then you get the final camera pose
in the map and the map is
the original map is created in kind of
the same method you just do this frame
to frame so
in consecutive camera frames you would
do this
feature matching and then triangulate 3d
key points and then
be able to create a similar map to what
you see here
so of course you know this is not an
easy problem which is why
a lot of people have been published a
lot of papers about it so there's
there's quite a few issues so here you
can see a 3d map
and examples of what a single key point
might look like over different lighting
conditions
and over time so uh as you can see
we're trying to focus in on this exact
point here
and it looks very different over
different seasons from different
perspectives
under different camera parameters
and at different times of day so it's
actually it's quite hard to do
this kind of descriptor matching over
time um
so how does how can we use this kind of
visual pipeline
uh to localize a robot so here you see a
work from
the autonomous systems lab at eth zurich
done with google tango tablets
so here they're demonstrating a
uh um basically an inspection trajectory
for a robot to fly
so by walking around with a tablet
they're recording this sparse visual map
which we see in yellow here
um and indicating points of interest
that the robot should inspect
so then by sending basically this 3d map
with visual features to the robot
the robot is able to localize itself to
the map
which is step one and then be able to
repeat this demonstrated trajectory
and inspect all of the points of
interest at hand
so even though the tablet and the robot
have very different sensors
they you know are obviously
quite a bit different they're able to
use the same visual features to
relocalize
uh so okay that's great there's a lot of
research on this
how can you use this so luckily there's
also a lot
of cloud services that offer this exact
functionality for
augmented reality and mixed reality
applications they include azure spatial
anchors which we'll talk about a little
bit more in a second
google cloud anchors and apple location
anchor so basically no matter what
platform you're using
there's at least some kind of
vision-based localization system for you
so um and most of these systems work
in a very similar way so basically
you're able to place
anchors which represent a common
reference frame
uh for you know attaching holograms to
replacing digital content or just having
some
persistent coordinate frame in the world
and
their goal is to keep it stable to the
real world so using armr
you know you physically place some
anchor that you want to stay the same
and by using kind of the visual features
in the environment
near the anchor
all of these systems use a very sim
similar method to what i just described
to
create a 3d visual map and um
enable you to relocalize back to this
anchor coordinate frame over time so
again yeah the most important thing uh
part of this is that it should be
persistent over time
um and all of these use the cloud uh
some of these
are optionally usable um
kind of on premises on-premises around
device
and you're able to attach cute dogs to
your anchors
and here's an example of uh so for azure
spatial anchors what this looks like in
the background so
this is uh this is an example of a scene
and here's what the visual map looks
like as you can see it's just a
collection
of 3d points and just looking at this
map you probably wouldn't be able to
really figure out what's what maybe this
is this shape here
that's possibly the edge of the chair
but the important thing is
each of these um 3d points actually
contains
a description of the local neighborhood
so here for example
on the edge of the chair you would have
this black to white transition
um and the kind of general local shape
of the chair uh described so you're able
to you know even if you view it from a
slightly different angle
at a slightly different time of day
you'll be able to re-recognize that
again
so here's kind of a video that that
shows how this is
how this works so here we're creating a
spatial anchors
um and then uh by kind of scanning the
space and getting enough data
the anchor is created and now we're able
to you know on multiple devices by both
localizing to the same anchor
we're able to share the space and uh you
know share the same view of a 3d model
so again this is just a way to anchor
digital information
to the physical world
how does the system work so we'll talk a
little bit
about specifically azure spatial anchors
and how you can use it in your work
so at release
azure spatial anchors worked with ar
core and air kit enabled devices so
iphone or android phones which took the
images and poses from the ar framework
also with hololens 1 and 2 which takes
basically in that case directly image
features and poses from the head
tracking
and most recently we've introduced the
azure spatial anchors linux sdk which
is a research distribution which allows
you to kind of bring your own
uh simultaneous localization and mapping
framework so you can get your poses from
from wherever you like all you need to
do is put in the undistorted images and
the poses of the camera
when those images were taken and you're
able to utilize this framework
this is all done within a session so a
session contains kind of the image
features and image poses
in a short span of time and from that
you can create anchors by specifying
a relative pose relative to the current
device position
and get a unique anchor id in return and
then other devices or yourself again can
query the same anchor id
and get the relative pose in return
so you can create anchors on any of the
devices
and query them again on any of the
devices shown here
which makes it quite a powerful system
the
the only restriction is you have to be
connected to azure this is a cloud-based
service and cloud-based service only
so let's take a look at how this works
on the real robot
so here's uh we see a hololens
localizing to
a spatial anchor this is the onboard
hololens view you can saw the coordinate
system just pop in
spot is able to localize to the same
anchor by using the
image data from one of its front facing
cameras
once both the hololens and the spot have
found the same anchor
they know each other's pose and their
pose relative to one another
this allows great human robot
interaction scenarios for example
sending spot to a goal from the hololens
point of view
and the come here gesture we showed at
the beginning of this presentation
so last of all we'll talk about the
scenario where
you actually don't have vision based
sensors or cameras on all of your
devices what if you have a robot that's
navigating the world using only lidar
can you still interact with it using a
mixed reality device how do you bring
both into the same coordinate system
we'll show a demo we've done of
co-localizing
a clearpath jackal which is using a 3d
lidar as its main sensor
together with a hollow lens doing kind
of the same demo we've shown with spot
to do this we first create a full 3d map
of the environment
using the hololens so the hololens has a
depth sensor on board as
jeff discussed and we use that to
reconstruct
a full uh 3d mesh of the environment
we then upload this to a server and then
extract
a 2d lidar occupancy map for the robot
to localize against so we need to give
it kind of a
rough guess of its of its pose and
basically now the hololens is localized
against
um a spatial anchor that's at the origin
of the map frame and the robot is
localized against
its 2d liner map which you can see here
this allows them to share the same
coordinate system even though they use
very different sensors and this allows
kind of the same
human robot interaction scenarios we've
we've discussed before
and here you see a top view of the 2d
lidar map that the robot is using some
obstacles overlaid on top of it
and the live sensor data
so in summary we think co-localization
is
crucial for human robot interaction with
mixed reality
and there's quite a few different ways
to do it so probably the simplest and
easiest is markers so
instrumenting your environment with some
kind of ar markers
then you can do much more complex
scenarios in unstructured environments
using vision based localization and we
discussed azure spatial anchors
linux sdk that allows you to
colloquialize your robot with mr devices
directly
and finally there is an approach to do
this through
a common map which we built on the
hololens
and in conclusion for the whole talk um
we hope that you've learned from this
that robotics and mixed reality are
natural
fit so mixed reality can give you
insight into robot state and plans more
natural interaction models and also get
information that actually the robot can
use
for increased autonomy we've also talked
about
many tools available to solve
fundamental co-localization problems
uh including vision based marker-based
and map-based
and we're really excited to to be a part
of a new and growing field of
mixed reality robot interaction and we
hope you've
you've kind of learned the tools to get
started here too
finally we want to thank everyone for
attending thank you so much for your
patience we really hope you enjoyed the
talk and learned a lot
please stay tuned for the q a and i'd
also like to give a special shout out to
um our amazing interns who really
heavily contributed to what we've shown
today
whereas waldo faro and eric volenviter
hello everyone thanks for attending our
webinar today on mixed reality and
robotics
my name is jeff del merico i'm here with
my colleague helen olenekova
we're going to start the live q a right
now and
for the next 15 minutes or so uh we'll
try to answer
some of the top questions from uh
from uh that you've submitted during the
webinar but please feel free to uh to
submit more questions if
uh you uh have any you know particular
topics you'd like to
know more about from uh from the webinar
or
more generally about mixed reality and
robotics uh if there are things we
didn't talk about
so i think i'll
start off with
the question that came to us
uh so how much do you lose in accuracy
and performance with
vision based localization versus ar tags
and markers
and uh what kind of settings can
vision-based localization be
reliably applied to um so
i think uh this fits into a more general
uh topic of sort of um
you know what what are the what are the
limitations of
uh of different localization
technologies
and uh so in
uh many applications at least
in terms of user experience for
ar and mr experiences
it's it's often uh the localization
localization accuracy
that really uh key pieces how it looks
to the user
and so if um
if for example your minecraft earth
or it is supposed to be on top of your
table and it's
three meters away uh floating in in
midair that's not a very good experience
for the user uh
in terms of localizing to um
to the visual features on
on your table um but on the other hand
if it's
only off by 15 or 20 centimeters
um then it it might look fine and so
that's sort of the requirements for
um for
human experiences um are somewhat
different than
uh than for uh robotic localization
where
if your robot is off by
20 centimeters it might bump into a door
so
um so currently
you know the the technology we have
for azure spatial anchors is
um accurate and reliable enough
to provide good user experiences
and as we look to the future we're also
interested in
trying to make these
vision-based localization also work for
the levels of accuracy that we need for
robotic tasks
maybe helen i'll hand it over to you for
the next question
yeah so the next question we wanted to
talk about which um
we thought was was interesting was how
do you see the roles of humans and
robots in a human robot collaboration
and i mean this is much more about kind
of our vision for the future and
you know as we discussed in the
presentation there's
uh like robots are becoming increasingly
more useful but where they're currently
most used commercially or at least what
we consider autonomous robots
is really just moving things from point
a to point b and logistic robots and
uh you know and in warehouses where
everything is flat everything is
pre-mapped and
the environment is somewhat known and
stationary and i think
really the next step it's not
necessarily that we're going to get
incredible autonomous robots that can do
everything
on their own and solve every problem and
uh you know do things that humans can't
even imagine doing
i think we're we're really a long way
off from that just because the these
problems are
very difficult to solve i think what
really is going to push robotics forward
a lot and making
robots much more useful is to be is to
enable humans to
do some of the decision making to have
humans and robots work
together side by side because some tasks
that might be
super simple for a human for instance
identifying
cups or figuring out how to pick
something up or figuring out the right
way to turn a part around for some
operation this is super easy for a human
and
can be really difficult for a robot
whereas you know lifting three tons
could be
very difficult for a human and super
easy for a robot so i think there's
really a lot of
many opportunities in this field for you
know
allowing humans to really use the
knowledge
and do the things that are very
difficult to do autonomously and
kind of do the um leave them more
mechanical work
and things that are much simpler for
robots to do to robots so i don't
i think it's going to be a very long
time before
robots can really replace humans and
in most spaces but hopefully they can
take away you know some of the dull
dirty and dangerous tasks or at least
help humans complete them in a safer
more efficient
uh and faster way
i'll hand it back to jeff for next
question thanks
uh i'll take the next one and this is
actually a couple of related questions
um about the azure spatial anchor
service
so uh the question was are there any
on-premises
solutions available for asa um
and do you plan to provide them or uh
you know
are there other solutions uh kind of
enterprise solutions to provide similar
functionality
and so um that's a good question because
you know currently uh the way that azure
spatial anchors works
you have to send data to the cloud so
you need to have a persistent
internet connection whether it's from
you know a mobile device or hololens or
now in this case
from from your robot um and
the you know the map is stored in the
cloud you don't download the map
you don't have that locally you can't
redirect your query to a local server
that all has to be done in the cloud
obviously that's a problem
for many robot scenarios if you think of
just like a large warehouse or factory
you might not have good wireless
connectivity throughout the space
or it might be expensive to provide that
and you know in a lot of the
other types of scenarios where you want
to
send robots to do um you know dangerous
jobs for example
uh there might not be any connectivity
at all
and um and so
uh you know we we certainly see the need
to relax
this uh this requirement and
the other dimension to this is that
often uh for
uh for enterprise customers you don't
necessarily want to put your
you know maps of your space in the um
in the cloud even if it's uh not
possible
for other users to retrieve that
information
um directly there's uh
certainly uh cases where uh users would
need to
have um have their their map data
um in in a more secure way and so
certainly we you know our ambition is to
be able to provide
um the mapping technology
to um to enable
these sorts of scenarios where um where
it's possible
to leverage the cloud when when that
makes sense and when it's also
possible to uh to have
uh on-premises maps that can be
queried through you know a local server
for customers that don't want to share
their data
in the cloud or can't send queries that
way
and also you know the there's definitely
a limitation on the scale
that we can support right now you know
individual
spatial anchors are relatively small
scale
and when placing them in a single
session they can
be you know connected together um
and uh and that's nice for still kind of
let's say office scale environments but
um you know the ambition is to to be
able to map
you know large uh as as another question
asked
um you know city street level uh city
blocks
large venues um factories and warehouses
things like that
so um you know we're we're very
interested in that our group
here in zurich works on um some of the
mapping technology that is um you know
geared towards
uh future looking things like this and
so
we're very interested in being able to
provide that in the future
maybe i'll hand this over to helen now
yes i'm looking for more questions that
would be interesting to answer
um
i think we've actually
uh done a pretty well we've been trying
to kind of answer most of these
as we go along uh in the chat
now let me read some of the newer ones
okay so i quite like this one
so the question is one of the
discussions suggested that
co-localization could be used to
consider human as an agent to enhance
safety
alongside robots given the reliability
on cloud
can it be trusted for safety of humans
or
is there a backup that you're working on
um so for sure
uh you know relying on cloud-based
localization as
a single degree of safety
is that's um that's certainly not safe
enough but i think there's applications
in especially industrial environments
where you know you can you have much
more control over
uh kind of what what the workers are
doing and so on that you know you can be
for instance required to wear some kind
of
mixed reality device or some kind of
localization device while performing
some
um some sort of task
and in these cases in addition to you
know more
standard industrial safety measures
um then the robot you know having more
insight about where a human might be or
might not be
it's just you know it's another source
of information maybe you have kind of
earlier warnings that a
person is approaching then then you
would just from
uh laser-based uh safety systems
so i think i i fully 100 agree that this
is like
not nearly safe safe enough as a single
layer
but i think there's an environment where
in addition to
you know uh many other failsafes it can
actually be quite useful
so i'll hand this back over to jeff
um yeah i just reading then
a couple more questions that we've
received
and uh we have another minute or two so
i
will probably just uh take this um
take this as the the last question for
now
um and uh
question do you observe much drift uh
with co-localization
between hololens and robot um
this is actually uh you know this this
hints at a at a broader class of of
uh sort of challenges for uh for doing
cross-device localization so if you
if you're mapping your space with visual
features right so you're calculating
features and
images that you see in the cameras on
one device let's say a hololens
then it's on your head and
you know particularly if you're a very
tall person but even if you're
a normal sized human you're quite a bit
taller than
uh most robots which are going to be
moving along the floor
and their cameras are also along the
floor so
the things that you see in the camera
images
on hololens that's on your head are
going to have a very different
perspective
um then the
then the what what you can see in
the camera images on a robot that's
walking along the ground
and um
be you know separate from
uh just the perspective you know if
you're looking down on
a table or you know even just on the
floor even if
if there's no occlusions um
the the way that you can see
uh features and and how those appear
to your uh to your device will
look different uh then to the robot and
that's not even considering differences
in you know uh in in focal length and
field of view
and resolution um there's a lot of
challenging
research questions uh for kind of
cross-device
place recognition that are
independent of um you know even just the
fact that you're
taller than your robot um
but that's definitely an issue it's it's
uh
you know with the azure spatial anchor
service
if you place anchors with
one device and you try to recall them
with another device
your performance your your
accuracy is going to be uh you know
noticeably different
um often it's still you know sufficient
to support the kind of ar
experiences that we want to provide
through
having these um having these these
uh spatial anchors but
often the accuracy is degraded quite a
bit compared to
uh recalling the anchor on the same
device or the same type of device
and so this is definitely uh something
you know
we need to consider as we you know if we
uh build maps from the robot that we
want the human to use
uh with with mobile or or head mounted
devices
or if we make maps with uh with human
devices and we want the robot to
localize to them
you know there is a challenge there to
achieve the same performance
as as when the devices are the same
and um
i think we're we're pretty much out of
time helen unless you have any
uh high priority final questions here
that just came in that you want to
answer
i think i'm all good from my side okay
um yeah so i just want to thank
all of you for uh for attending today
for submitting lots of really great
questions
um really appreciate your
your interest in the subject and uh um
we i think somewhere within your view uh
there's a resource list uh on on the
right
that uh has some some links we've done
some there should be uh hopefully a few
things of interest for you there a
recent blog post
and some also uh some links to github
with code samples
um and uh i'd also like to call your
attention
to uh to the poll i'm not sure where
that is in your view
but if you can take a moment to answer
uh i think there's only four questions
uh just to
help us get a better understanding of of
the audience here
that will uh inform our you know kind of
future communications as well
and uh and uh certainly
you know thank you for taking the time
and thanks for your interest and
do reach out to us if uh
in the future if you have have further
questions and so on
um great thanks so much have a great day